[Applause]
[Music]
I I know I'm excited I'm so excited um
wait okay so wait I'm going to first
start with um the holidays are here you
look beautiful and red by the way this
is a color I'm really trying to ground
myself because I'm looking into your
eyes and this is so cool oh my God same
and I literally and I was so excited cuz
last night I was like reading up I
always do like my homework before I
because I know things about like your
work but I don't I never like the person
knows personal thing I I'll work oh my
go any I oh my god well I have seen
everything you're in I saw from Justin
to Kelly the day it came out oh my God
that's a real fan okay is not good um I
I never we're going to get into that
acting versus singing but before we get
there like for the holidays do you get
into this are you I I feel like I I know
I was reading up on you I feel like
we're you love giving gifts I love
giving gifts thoughtful too started I'm
like a month in already I usually start
in October yeah yeah yeah because I feel
like it starts to come you start to see
things and you go oh I should get that
for this person and why wait and if you
wait it all of a sudden everything hits
you and you have no time exactly and I
also like to wrap my presence me too
really well me too yes I make all the
tags it's a whole thing people offer to
do it and I'm offended I'm like no
you're going to run it yeah yeah I do
the like bits and bobles I do tag I do
everything I have a theme every year
it's a thing it's a thing this year I
think I'm going with just solid
parchment like CL with with twine cuz
usually yes brown paper package color no
I did that a couple years ago I love you
so much we should be
[Music]
[Applause]
friends thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home